翻訳: Mami Iwamura
校正: Hiroko Kawano
今日は 私のパーソナルストーリーから
始めたいと思います
この数字 何かわかる方
おられますでしょうか？
最初の6,434
これは20年前に 阪神淡路大震災で
亡くなられた方の数です
そのあとの数字 約2.5倍
これが4年前に東日本大震災で
亡くなられた方の数です
大変残念な事に これが私の
今の故郷の現状です
これは本当に私の人生観を変えるような
大きい出来事でした
その時に私は自分の故郷を
何か今まで以上に新しい物に変えないと
福島は
やっていけないんじゃないかという風に
非常に危機感を覚えました
会津若松は観光で成り立っている町です
観光の町
90%の観光客の方がいなくなってしまいました
自分の大好きな町
歩いてみると ほとんど人がいません
本当にゴーストタウンのような状況でした
私自身も 生きるのが精一杯で
故郷のために何かしたいと
思っておりましたけれども
なかなか形にできなくて
非常に歯がゆい思いもしました
その時にふと頭に浮かんだ
アイデアがありました
自転車です
なぜ自転車かといいますと
観光客の方 戻ってきてもらうのに
無料でシェアサイクルを広げたら
どうだろう？
というのがそもそものきっかけです
そこで自転車について
ちょっと考えてみましょう
今 自転車 毎年
1億3千万台も作られています
1億3千万ですよ
毎年新しい自転車ですよ
皆さん 凄いですよね
また 自転車を使った
新しい取り組みとして
シェアサイクルという動きが
世界的な潮流として始まっています
アメリカだったり
ヨーロッパだったり
台湾だったり
これは3月26日に始まった
神戸でのシェアサイクルなんですけれども
この中で 神戸でシェアサイクルに
乗ったって方どれくらいいらっしゃいますか？
手を挙げてもらってもいいですか？
あ なんか少ないですね
もっと皆さん 自転車乗りましょう
自転車なんですけれども
200年前にドイツで発明されました
それからですね
自転車
まあ基本皆さん 自転車を考えてもらったら
わかると思うんですけれども
車輪が二つ付いています
ただ動くだけです
特に何もイノベーションはありませんよね
それがずっと200年続いてきました
シェアサイクルも非常に今
世界中では広がっていますけれども
シェアサイクル
ただ自転車を貸して
自転車を貸したお金しか貰えないという
ビジネスモデルです
特にこれから人口減少
少子高齢化のような
日本とか そういう国
そういう新しい交通
モビリティが必要だと思っています
例えば東京とかロンドンを考えてみましょう
基本的には人口減少の世の中です
ですけれども 例えばオリンピック
一時的にインバウンドで
観光客の方が皆さん ばっと来ます
その時に今までの
高速道路だったりとか
大きい鉄道だったり
そういう今までの重厚長大な
インフラに投資したとします
その時は良いでしょう
その後 どうやって
皆さん 支えますか?
支えられないですよね
ですので 自転車は全ての解決法
だとは思いません
ですけれども 私は自転車は
解決方法の一つ
オプションの一つだと思っています
そこで私は「車輪の再発明」を
することにしました
「車輪の再発明」って
ご存じの方いるかと思うんですけれども
プログラマーの世界では
車輪の再発明というと
凄く 車輪という存在を知っているけれども
それ以上の物を作る
物凄い天才の人か
車輪自体を知らない
本当に馬鹿な人か
二種類に分かれます
私はこれから自分が天才である
証明をしなくてはなりません
例えば 自転車
今皆さん 自分で自転車って
所有する物だと思うんですけれども
例えば自転車が公共財だと思ったら
皆さんどうでしょう？
公共財というのは自分の所有物ではなくて
皆さんが全員で共有できる
社会全体の持ち物です
例えば皆さん 傘とか自転車って
盗まれた事がある方って
いっぱいいますよね
あれはちょっとやっぱり
頭にきますよね
ですけれども 例えば
自転車とか傘が
普遍的にその辺
どこにでもあったら皆さんどうでしょう？
空気盗みたいって方はいませんよね
それが公共財です
公共財になった自転車を
考えた時に
どういう事が出来るか
ちょっと考えてみましょう
これが私の作った
「FUKUSHIMA Wheel」の概念図です
自転車には大きく分けて
三つの物が付いています
スマートフォンのアプリケーション
これはクラウドに繋がっています
もう一つは車輪のLED
三つ目が環境のセンサーです
その三つが「FUKUSHIMA Wheel」
を構成しています
今 シェアサイクルを借りようと思うと
ステーションに返さなくてはいけません
ですけれども 今
スマートフォンで開くような
スマートロックという装置があります
そういう物とうまく組み合わせる事によって
例えば自転車をどこかに置くと
置いた後に
スマホを付けるだけで
ロックが解除されたりとか
そういう事が可能になります
それが出来るとどうなるでしょう？
この前の震災の時に
非常に大きな問題となったのは
首都圏では 帰宅難民の方が
大量に出た事です
皆さんも神戸の震災の時に
逃げられなかったという方も
おられるかもしれません
もし明日
阪神淡路大震災のようなもの
例えば東日本大震災のような
大震災が起きた時に
普遍的に 自転車が町にあったら
この前の震災のように悲しい思いをする人が
少しでも減るかもしれません
また自転車を使う事によって
それぞれの点
都市のリソースを
最適化する事が出来ます
例えば私は今ここに住んでおりませんので
自転車がありません
で 例えば私が使いたいと
言った時に
貸してくれたら凄く助かりますよね
貸す方はそれでお金を貰えたら
もっと楽しいかもしれません
後は 自転車を使った
都市全体のロジスティックを
マネジメント出来るようになると
アイスクリーム
例えば 今欲しいなと
例えばアプリで呟いたとすると
すぐ近くのコンビニにいる方が
アイスを買って届けてくれる
おつかいですね
それを頼む事もできます
また自転車には
環境のセンサーが付いています
環境のセンサーには
いま 気温と湿度 後はCO ノックス
後は放射線量のセンサーが付いています
ただ自転車でその辺を走るだけで
自分の町がどのぐらい
大気汚染になってるのかとか
どのぐらい放射線量があるのか
っていうのがわかりますよね
また自転車に着けられたセンサーが
データを計測します
そのデータは全てクラウドに集約されます
いわゆる情報の可視化ですね
これはビッグデータにも応用できます
こういった「可視化」を
することによって
みなさんが住んでいる町の問題を
一つ一つ解決していく事ができると
信じています
そこでシェアサイクルを
ちょっと考えてみましょう
シェアサイクル 非常に良い事ばかりな
ような気がするんですけども
例えば渋滞が減ります
ですけれども大きい問題があります
大企業が企業のイメージの向上の為に
シェアサイクルのプログラムを
やっています
もう一つ 自治体が
非常に巨額な助成金を使って
税金を使って
シェアサイクルを
運用しているケースがほとんどです
つまりシェアサイクルというのは
ビジネス的には持続可能性が
あまりないものが非常に多いと思います
そこで私たちの「車輪の再発明」を使って
どうやって持続可能性なモデルに
シェアサイクルをしていくのかというのが
私の新しいチャレンジです
そこで私は車輪にLEDを付けました
回ると ここに広告が出ます
これは位置情報であったり
時間で
広告を自由に ダイナミックに
出す事が出来ます
例えば町に千台の自転車が
走っていたとします
そうすると色々なお店の前で
そこの広告が出たりとか
あとは 3時にタイムセールが
始まるという時は
「何とかセール」と出したりとか
そういう事が出来ます
また 私たちはソフトウェアを
使う事によって
上り坂と下り坂の値段を変えたりとか
混んでいるステーションではなくて
こっちのステーションに返すと
値段が安いよ とか
後は 今日はTEDx
皆 自転車乗りたくなりますよね
そういう時は値段を上げるとか
そういった事が可能になります
（笑）
今 お話したような世界を
実現したようなムービーを作ってみました
是非見てみて下さい
（音楽）
[車輪の再発明]
こういったスマートロックを
使うことによって
今までステーションにあったような
シェアサイクルというのが
どこにでも停めて
どこでも借りる事が出来ます
センサーで どのぐらいの
カロリーを使ったかとか
周りの気温とか湿度とか
窒素化合物とか一酸化炭素というのが
どのぐらいのデータ
町がどのぐらいクリーンなのか
というのが分かります
また このデータは全て
クラウドで集約されて
他の方と共有することが出来ます
例えばこういう観光客の方
自分が今どこにいるのか
よくわからないけれども
GPSがどこにいるか教えてくれます
またそのGPSが近くにある自転車を
自動的に教えてくれます
今 車に乗る時にナビゲーションを
使うのって普通ですよね
自転車にも付けてみました
これを使う事によって
例えば観光地だったりだとか
そこで 旅で得たような経験というのを
友人や知っている方に共有する事ができます
また自転車というのは 非常に
健康的な生活だったりとか
持続可能性がある社会を実現するための
プラットフォームになり得ます
こういう渋滞よくありますよね
皆さん 今度
自転車乗ってみたらどうです？
こういう風に 走ってると
車輪に広告が出ます
もちろんセルフィー撮って
それを出す事も出来ます
どうですか 皆さん？
こんな自転車がその辺を走ってたら
ワクワクしません？
（拍手）
このアイデアを実現する為に
私は今 世界中を飛び回っています
アメリカ､ヨーロッパ ､アジア､ 日本
色んな国に行きました
自転車は 基本 二輪あります
一輪が福島だとすると
もう一つの車輪が皆さんの町です
世界中の色んな町は
色んな問題を抱えています
私の「車輪の再発明」というのは
そういう問題を解決できると
信じています
漆の産地でもあります
漆の技法でもある
「金継ぎ」という技法があります
これは 割れて壊れてしまった
茶碗や陶器を 漆と金を使って
もう一度復元するものです
震災というのは
「割れてしまった器」を
作ってしまったと思います
でも 茶の湯の世界
金継ぎの世界では
割れた茶碗のかけらを
金と漆で 復元する事によって
より 前よりも大切に使う
それは もっと価値が上がる
という事です
これは私が「車輪の再発明」で
やっている事は
地元への「金継ぎ」に
他なりません
自転車 今まで
個人の所有物だと思っていた自転車を
例えば公共財にしたという風に
思ったとき
世の中はどういう風に変わるでしょう?
今まで皆さんが当たり前のように
これは「個人で所有する物」だという物が
公共財になった時
どういう世の中になるでしょう？
是非 考えてみて下さい
さて 最後にですね
私のショウタイムを始めたいと思います
（拍手）
これからですね
私が 自転車の車輪を回します
その時に 私
スリーツーワンと言います
そしたら皆さん 大きい声で
「ショウタイム」と言って下さい
ショウタイムの声が低いと
私 非常に恥ずかしいので
（笑）
あと スリーツーで
「ショウタイム」じゃなくて
「スリーツーワン」と言った後に
「ショウタイム」と言って下さいね
良いですか？
予行練習はしないですよ
じゃあ
スリー
ツー
ワン
「ショウタイム」
（歓声）
（拍手）
以上で私のトークを
終わりにさせて頂きたいと思います
どうもありがとうございました
（拍手）